the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
all right everyone let's get started
so so today's this is going to be the
section second lecture on
object-oriented programming so just a
quick recap of last time on Monday we
saw we were introduced to this idea of
object-oriented programming and we saw
these things called abstract data types
and these abstract data types we
implemented through Python classes and
they allowed us to create our own data
types that sort of abstracted a general
object of our choosing right so we've
used lists before for example but with
abstract data types we were able to
create objects that were of our own
types we saw the coordinate example and
then at the end of the class we saw the
fraction example so today we're going to
talk a little bit more about
object-oriented programming and classes
we're going to see a few more examples
and we're going to talk about a few
other nuances of classes talk about
information information hiding and class
variables and in the second half of the
lecture we're going to talk about the
idea of inheritance so we're going to
use object-oriented programming to sort
of simulate how to simulate how real
life works so in real life you have
inheritance and in in object-oriented
programming you can also simulate that
okay so the first few slides are going
to be a little bit of recap just to make
sure that everyone's on the same page
before I introduce a couple of new
concepts related to classes so recall
that when in the last lecture we we
talked about writing code from two
different perspectives right the first
was from someone who wanted to implement
a class so implementing the classmate
defining your own object type so you
define the object type when you define
the class and then you decided what data
attributes you wanted to define your
object so what what data makes up the
object what is the object okay in
addition to data attributes we also saw
these things called methods and methods
were ways to tell someone how to
use your data type so what are ways
that's that someone can interact with
the data type okay so that's from the
point of view of someone who wants to
write their own object type
so you're implementing you're
implementing a class and the other
perspective was to write code from the
point of view of someone who wanted to
use a class that was already written
okay so this involved creating instances
of objects so you're using the object
type once you created instances of
objects you're able to do operations on
them so you're able to see what methods
whoever implemented the class added and
then you can use those methods in order
to do operations with your instances so
just looking at the coordinate example
we saw last time a little bit more in
detail about what that meant so we had a
class definition of an object type which
included deciding what the class name
what the class name was and the class
name basically told Python what type of
an object this was okay in this case we
decided we wanted to name a coordinate
we wanted to create a coordinate object
and the type of this object was
therefore going to be a coordinate we
define the class in the sort of general
way okay so we needed a way to be able
to access data attributes of any
instance so we use this self variable
okay and the self variable was we we
used to refer to any instance to the
data attributes of any instance in a
sort of general way without actually
having a particular instance in mind
okay so whenever we access data
attributes we would say something like
self dot to access a data attribute
you'd access the attribute directly with
self dot X or if you wanted to access a
method you would say self dot and then
the method name for example distance and
really the bottom line of the class
definition is that your class defines
all of the data so data attributes and
all of the methods that are going to be
common across all of the instances so
any instance that you create of a
particular object type that instance is
going to have
this exact same structure okay the
difference is that every instances
values are going to be different so when
you're creating instances of classes you
can create more than one instance of the
same class so we can create a coordinate
object here using this syntax right here
so you say the type and then whatever
values it takes in and you can create
more than one coordinate object each
coordinate object is going to have
different data attributes sorry it's
going to have different data attribute
values okay every coordinate object is
going to have an X value and a Y value
but the x and y values among different
instances are going to are going to vary
okay so that was that's the difference
between defining a class and looking at
a particular instance of class so
instances have the structure of the
class so for a coordinate and in all
instances have an x value and a Y value
but the actual values are going to vary
between the different instances okay
so ultimately why do we want to use
object-oriented programming so so far
the examples that we've seen are word
numerical right a coordinate a fraction
but object or using object-oriented
programming you can create objects that
mimic real-life so if I wanted to create
objects of an object that defined a cat
in an object that defined a rabbit I
could do that with object-oriented
programming I would just have to decide
as a programmer what data and what
methods I'd want to assign to to these
to these groups of objects okay so using
object-oriented programming each one of
these is considered a different object
and as a different object I can decide
that a cat is going to have a name an
age and maybe a color associated with it
and these three here on the right each
one of these rabbits is also an object
and I'm going to decide that I'm going
to represent a rabbit by just
agent and a color okay and with
object-oriented programming I can using
these using these attributes I can sort
of group these three objects together
and these three objects together okay so
I'm grouping sets of objects that are
going to have the same attributes
together and attributes this is also a
recap of last time come in two forms
right data attributes and procedural
attributes so the data attributes are
basically things like are basically
things that define what the object is so
how do you represent a cat as an object
and it's up to you as the programmer to
decide how you want to do that for
coordinate it was pretty pretty
straightforward you had an X and a
y-value if we're representing something
more abstract like an animal then maybe
I would say well I'm going to represent
an animal by an age and a name okay so
it's really up to you to decide how you
want to represent what data attributes
you want to have to have to represent
your object with procedural attributes
were also known as methods and the
methods are essentially asking what can
your object do okay so how can someone
who wants to use your object how can
someone interact with it so for a
coordinate we saw that you can find the
distance between two coordinates maybe
for more abstract animal object you
might make it you might have it make a
sound
okay by maybe printing to the screen or
something like that
okay this slides also a recap of how to
create a class just to make sure
everyone's on the same page before we go
on so we defined a class using this
class keyword and we said class the name
of the class so now we're going to
create a more abstract animal class
we're going to see in the second half of
the lecture what it means to put
something else in the parentheses but
for now we say that an animal in an
animal is an object
in Python so that means it's going to be
it's going to have all of the properties
that any other object in Python has and
as we're creating this animal we're
going to define how to create an
instance of this class so we say de f
and this init was the special method
that told Python how to create an object
inside the parentheses remember we have
the self which is a variable that we
used to refer to any instance of the
class okay we don't have a particular
instance in mind we just want to be able
to refer to any instance okay so we use
this self variable and then in here and
then the second parameter here is going
to represent what other data we use to
initialize our object with so in this
case I'm going to say I'm going to
initialize an animal object with an H
okay so when I create an animal I need
to give it an age inside the init are
any initializations that i want to make
so the first thing is I'm going to
assign an instance variable age so this
is going to be the data attribute age to
be whatever's passed in and then I'm
also making another assignment here
where I'm assigning the data attribute
name to be none originally later on in
the code when I want to create an animal
object I say the class name and then I
pass it in whatever parameters it takes
in this case the age and I'm assigning
it to this instance here okay alright so
now we have this class animal we've done
the first part here which is to
initialize the class right so we've told
Python how to create an object of this
type there's a few other methods here
that I've implemented next - we call
getters and the two after that we call
setters and getters and setters are very
commonly used when when it when when
implementing a class so getters
essentially return the values of any of
the data attributes
so if you look carefully yet age is just
returning self dot age and get name just
return self name so they're very simple
methods similarly set agents that name
we're going to see what this what this
funny equal sign is doing here in the
next couple of slides but setters do a
very similar thing where they're going
to set the data attributes to whatever
is passed in okay so those are getters
and setters and then the last thing down
here is this STR method and this STR
method is used to tell Python how to
print an object of this type animal so
if you didn't have this STR method if
you remember from last lecture what ends
up happening is you're going to get some
message when you print your object that
says this is an object of type animal at
this memory location which is very
uninformative right so you implement
this method here which tells python how
to print an object of this type okay so
the big point of this slide is that you
should be using getters and setters you
should be implementing getters and
setters for your classes and we're going
to see in the next couple of slides why
exactly but basically they're going to
prevent bugs from from coming into play
later on if someone decides to change
the implementation so we saw how to so
the previous slide this slide here shows
the implementation of the animal class
and here we can see how we can create an
instance of this object so we can say a
is equal to animal 3 so this is going to
create a new animal object with an age
of 3 and we can access the object
through the variable a dot notation
recall is a way for you to access data
attributes and methods of a class okay
so you can say a dot age later on in
your program and that is allowed it'll
try to access the age data attribute of
this particular instance of the class a
so this is going to give you 3 however
it's actually not rec
to access data attributes directly so
this is the reason so you're going to
see on the next slide the reason why
we're going to use getters and setters
instead you should use the get age
getter method to get the age of of the
animal so this is going to return also
three so these are going to do the same
thing and the reason why you'd want to
use getters and setters is this idea of
information hiding okay so the whole
reason why we're using classes and
object-oriented programming is so that
you can abstract certain certain data
from the user okay one of the things you
you should be abstracting is these these
data attributes so users shouldn't
really need to know how a class is
implemented they just they should just
know how to use the class okay so
consider the following case let's say
whoever wrote the animal class wants to
change the implementation and they've
decided they don't want to call the data
attribute age anymore they want to call
it years okay so when they initialize an
animal they say self dot years is equal
to age so an animal still gets
initialized by its age and the age gets
passed into a data attribute named years
okay since I'm implementing this class I
want to have a getter which is going to
return self dot years so I'm not
returning self age anymore because age
is no longer the data attribute I'm
using so with this new implementation if
someone was using if someone was using
this implementation and was accessing
age directly as as accessing the data
attribute age directly with this new
implementation they'd actually get an
error right because this animal that
they created using my old implementation
no longer has an attribute named age and
so python is going to spit out an error
saying no attribute found or something
like that okay if they were using the
getter a dot get age the person who
implemented the class re-implemented get
age to work correctly right with their
new data attribute years as opposed to
age so if I was using the getter
get age I wouldn't have run into the bug
okay so things to remember use getters
and right getters and setters for your
classes and later on in your code use
getters and setters to prevent bugs and
and to promote easy to maintain code
okay so information hiding is great but
having said that pythons actually not
very great at information hiding okay
Python allows you to do certain things
that you should never be doing okay so
the first we've just seen so it's 2x the
first is to access data attributes from
outside of the class okay so if I were
to say a dot age Python allows me to do
that without using a getter and setter
Python also allows you to write to data
attributes from outside the class so if
I implemented the class animal assuming
that age was a number an integer and all
of my methods work as long as age as an
integer but someone decided to be smart
and outside of the class set age to be
infinite as a string that might cause
the code to crash okay
Python allows you to do that but now
you're breaking the fact that age has to
be an integer right so now the methods
should probably be checking the fact
that age is an integer all the time the
other thing that you're allowed to do is
to create data attributes outside of the
class definition okay
so if I wanted to create a new data
attribute called size for this
particular instance Python also allows
me to do that and I can set it to
whatever I want so Python allows you to
do all these things but it's actually
not good style to do any of them so just
don't do it all right so the last thing
I want to mention the last thing about
class is before we go on to inheritance
is this idea called default arguments
and default arguments are passed into
methods and since methods or functions
you can also pass in default arguments
to functions
so for example this setname method had
self and then this new name is equal to
this empty string here okay we haven't
seen this before but this is called a
default argument and you can use the
function in one of two ways
the first way is so we can create a new
instance of an animal type object with
this line here a is equal to animal 3
and then we can say a dot set name so
this calls the setter method to set the
name and notice we've always said that
you have to put in parameters for
everything other than self ok but here
we have no parameters passed in but
that's ok because new name actually has
a default argument ok so that tells
Python if no parameters passed in for
this particular formal parameter then
use whatever is up here by default so if
I haven't passing the parameter a
detonate a dot set name sorry a dot set
name is going to be setting the name to
the empty string because that's what the
default parameter is so in the next line
when I print a dog get name this is just
going to print the empty string ok if
you do want to pass in a parameter you
can do so as as as normal so you can say
is equal to animal 3 a dot set name and
then pass in a parameter here and then
new name is going to be assigned to
whatever parameters passed in like that
whatever you pass in overrides the
default argument and everything is is
good so when I print a dot get name this
is going to print out the name that you
that you've passed in questions about
default yeah
what if you don't provide a default
value for for new name if you don't
provide a default argument for a new
name and you do this case here then
that's going to give you an error so
python is going to say something like
expected one argument god zero or
something like that great question
okay all right so let's move on to this
idea of hierarchies okay so the great
thing about object-oriented programming
is that it allows us to add layers of
abstraction to our code right so we
don't need to know how very very
low-level things are implemented in
order to use them and we can build up
love we can build up our code to be more
and more complex as we use up these
different these different abstractions
so consider every one of these things on
this slide as being a separate object
right every one of these things is can
be considered to be an animal okay
according to our implementation of an
animal the one thing that an animal has
is an age okay and that's probably true
right every one of these things has an
age but now I want to build up on this
and create separate groups right and
each one of these separate groups that I
create on top of animal is going to have
its own functionality right they're
going to be a little bit more specific
and more specialized so I can create
these three groups now a cat a rabbit
and a person group and for example so
they're all animals right they all have
an age but for example maybe a person's
going to have a list of friends where as
a cat and a rabbit do not maybe a cat
has a data attribute for the number of
lives they have left right whereas a
person in a rabbit do not okay so you
can think of adding these more
specialized adding more adding
functionality to each one of these
subgroups okay so we're going to be more
and more specialized but all of them
retaining the fact that they are animals
they all have an age for it
sample so on top of these we can add
another layer and say that a student is
a person and is an animal okay but in
addition to having an age and maybe also
having a list of friends a student might
also have a major or they're pretty
young so maybe their favorite you know
their favorite subject in school so so
that's the general idea of of
hierarchies okay so we can sort of
abstract the previous the previous slide
into this one and say that we have
parent classes and child classes
okay the animal class is like our parent
class it's the highest level class
inheriting from the animal class we have
these child classes or subclasses okay
whatever an animal can do a person can
do whatever an animal can do a cat can
do and whatever an animal can do a
rabbit can do okay
that is have an age and maybe some
really basic functionality but between
person cat and rabbit they're going to
be varying wildly as to the kinds of
things that they can do right but they
can all do whatever animal can do so
child classes inherit all of the data
attributes and all of the methods or
behaviors that their parents classes
have but child classes can add more
information like for example a person
can have a list of friends where as a
general animal will not it could add
more behavior like maybe a cat can climb
trees whereas people and rabbits cannot
or you can also override behavior so in
the previous one we had animal person
student so maybe we have an animal
doesn't speak at all but a person can
speak so that's added functionality to
the person and maybe a person can only
say hello but then when we talk to a
student we can override the fact
override the speak method of a person
and say that a student can say you know
I have homework or I need sleep or
something like that okay so we have the
same speak method for both person and
student because they can both speak but
student will override the fact that they
say hello with something else okay
so let's look at some code to put this
into perspective so we have this animal
class which we've seen before this is
the parent class okay it inherits from
object which means that everything that
a basic object can do in Python and an
animal can do which is things like
binding variables you know very low
level things okay we've seen the init
we've seen the two getters the setters
and the string method to to print an
object of type of animal all right now
let's create a subclass of animal we'll
call it cat okay we create a class named
cat in parentheses instead of putting
object we now put animal and this tells
python that cat is going cats parent
class is animal so everything that an
animal can do a cat can do so that
includes all of the attributes which was
age and name and all of the methods so
all the getters the setters the str the
init everything that the animal had now
the cat has the cat class has in the cat
class we're going to add two different
two more methods though they the first
to speak so when so so speak is going to
be a method that's going to just take in
the self okay no other parameters and
all it's doing is printing me out to the
screen very simple okay so this through
the speak we've added new functionality
to the to the class so an animal
couldn't speak whereas the cat says meow
additionally through this STR method
here we're overriding the animal STR
okay so if we go back to the previous
slide we can see that an animal the
animals STR had animal plus the name
plus the age here whereas the cats STR
now says cat name and the age okay so
this is just how I chose to implement
this okay so here I've overridden the
STR method of of the animal class
notice that this class doesn't have an
in it and that's okay because pythons
actually going to say well if there's no
in it in this particular method sorry in
this particular class then look to my
parents and say do my parents happen in
it and if so use that in it so that's
actually true for any other methods so
the idea here is when you have
hierarchies you have a parent class you
have a child class you can have a child
class that child class and so on and so
on so you can have multiple levels of
inheritance what happens when you create
an object that is of type something
that's that's been of a type that's the
this the child class of a child class of
a child class right what happens when
you call a method on that object
well python is going to say does the
method as a method with that name exist
in my current class definition and if so
use that but if not then look to my
parents do my parents know how to do
that right do my parents have a method
for whatever I want to do if so use that
if not look to their parents and so on
and so on so it's you're sort of tracing
back up your ancestry to figure out if
you can do this this method or not so
let's look at a slightly more
complicated example we have a class
named person it's going to inherit from
animal inside this person I'm going to
create my own I'm going to create an
init method and the unit method is going
to do something different than what the
animal's init method is doing it's going
to take in self as usual and it's going
to take into parameters as opposed to
one a name and an age first in the init
methods doing is its calling the animals
init method why am i doing that well I
could theoretically initialize the the
name and the age data attributes that
animal initializes in this method but
I'm using the fact that I've already
written code that initializes those two
data attributes so why not just use it
okay so here this says I'm going to call
the class animal I'm going to call it
init method and I'm going to leave it up
to you - not you as the class but I'm
talking to as as program is running I'm
going to leave it up to you to figure
out how to initialize an animal with
with this particular age and what to
name it so Python says yep I know how to
do this so I'm going to go ahead and do
that for you so now it says person is an
animal and I've initialized the age and
the name for you the next thing I'm
doing in the unit is I'm going to set
the name to whatever name was passed in
okay so when the init notice I can do
whatever I want including calling
function calling methods and then the
last thing I'm doing here is I'm going
to create a new data attribute for a
person which is a list of friends okay
so an animal didn't have a list of
friends but a person is going to the
next four methods here are this one's a
getter so it's going to return the list
of friends this is going to append a
friend to the end of my list I'm making
I want to make a note that I actually
didn't write a method to remove friends
so once you get a friend they're friends
for life
but that's okay the next method here is
speak which is going to print hello to
the screen and the last method here is
going to get the age difference between
two people so that just basically
subtracts their age and says it's a five
year age difference or whatever it is
and down here I have an STR method which
I've overridden from the animal which
instead of animal colon name it's going
to say person : name : age
so we can run this code
so let's down here I have an animal
person here so I'm going to run this
code and what did i do I created a new
person I gave it a name and an age I
created another person then name in an
age and here I've just run some methods
on it which was get name get age get
name get age for each of the two people
so that printed jack is thirty Jill is
twenty five if I print p1 this is going
to use the STR method of person so it's
going to print person : their name and
then their age P 1 dot speaks just says
hello and then the age difference
between p1 and p2 is just five so that's
just subtracting and then telling
printing that up to the screen okay so
that's my person let's add another class
this class is going to be a student and
it's going to be a subclass of person
since it's a subclass of person it's
going to a student is going to inherit
all the attributes of a person and
therefore all the attributes of an
animal the init method of a student is
going to be a little different from the
one of a person we're going to give it a
name an age and a major notice we're
using default arguments here so if I
create a student without giving it a
major the major is going to be set to
none originally once again this line
here person dot in it self name age
tells python hey you didn't already know
how to initialize a person for me with
this name in this age so can you just do
that and Python says yes I can do that
for you and so that saves you maybe like
five lines of code just by calling the
init method that you've already written
through person okay
so student has been initialized to be a
person and additionally we're going to
set another data attribute for the
student to be the major
and we're going to set the major to be
nun the student is going to get this
Center here
the setter method which is going to
change the major to whatever else they
want if they want to change it and then
I'm going to override the speak method
so the speak method for the person
recall just said hello a student is
going to be a little bit more complex
I'm going to use the fact that someone
created this random class okay so this
is where we can write more interesting
code by using by reusing code that other
people have written so someone wrote a
random class that can do cool things
with random numbers so if I want to use
random numbers in my code I'm going to
put this import random at the top of my
code which essentially brings in all of
the methods for the random class one of
the methods being this random method so
random open closed parenthesis is random
method from the random class and this
essentially gives me a number between 0
and 1 including 0 but not including 1 ok
so this random number I get here is
going to help me write my method for
speak where it's going to with Quarter
25 percent probability it's either going
to say I have homework I need sleep I
should eat or I'm watching TV ok
so student is going to say one of those
four things and the last thing I'm doing
down here is overriding the STR method
so let's look at the code I'm going to
comment this part out and uncomment the
student and see what we get ok so here I
am creating the student I'm creating one
student whose major is yes name is Alice
and ages 20s 2 is going to be another
student named Beth age 18 and the major
is going to be none because I didn't
pass in any major here so by default
using the default argument it's going to
be none if I print s1 as 2 that's going
to print out these 2 things over here
just buy whatever STR method does
and then I'm going to get the students
to speak and if I run it multiple times
you can see that it's going to print
different things each time so I need
sleep I have homework I need sleep I
have homework yeah so every time it's
going to print something different okay
questions about inheritance this example
okay last thing we're going to talk
about in this class is an idea of or in
this lecture is the idea of a class
variable so to illustrate this I'm going
to create yet another subclass of my
animal called a rabbit so class
variables so so far we've seen sorry let
me back up so so far we've seen instance
variables right so things like self dot
name self dot age those are all instance
variables so they're variables that are
specific there are common across all of
the instances of the class right every
instance of the class has this
particular variable but the value of the
variable is going to be different
between all of the different instances
so class variables are going to be
variables whose value is whose values
are shared between all of the instances
in the class so if if one instance of
the class modifies this class variable
that any other instance of the class is
going to see the modified value so it's
sort of shared among all of the
different instances so we're going to
use class variables to keep track of
rabbits
okay so we're creating this class rabbit
tag is equal to one we haven't seen
something like this before so tag is our
class variable class variables are
typically defined inside the class
definition but right but outside of the
init so tag is going to be a class
variable and I'm initializing it to one
inside the in it this tells us how to
create a rabbit object so I'm going to
give itself as usual an age and then two
parents don't worry about the two
parents for now inside the in it sorry
inside the in it I'm going to call the
init of the animal because just to do
less work Python already knows how to
initialize an animal for me so let's do
that so that's going to set the two data
attributes name and age I'm going to set
the data attributes for parent one
parent two for a rabbit to be whatever
is passed in and then this is where I'm
going to use this class variable so I'm
creating this data attribute instance
variable particular to a specific
instance called our ID okay and I'm
assigning this this instance variable to
the class variable and I access class
variables using not self but the class
name so in this case rabbit tag so
initially tag is going to be 1 and then
the init is going to increment the tag
by 1 here okay so that means that from
now on if I create any other instances
the other instances are going to be
accessing the updated value of tag
instead of being one so let's do a quick
drawing to show you what I mean so let's
say I have rabbit dot tag here okay
so initially tag is going to be one okay
and then I'm going to create a new
rabbit object so this is as I'm calling
the code okay so let's say this is a
rabbit object oh boy okay
r1 you know I actually googled how to
draw a rabbit but that didn't help at
all okay so r1 is going to be a new
rabbit that we create initially what
happens is when I first create this new
rabbit it's going to access the class
variable which is current value is
one so when I create the rabbit ID the
rabbit ID R 1 dot R ID this is going to
get the value 1 and according to the
code after I set the rabbit ID to
whatever tag is I'm going to increment
the tag so this is going to say okay now
that I've said it I'm going to go back
up here and increment the tag to be 2
okay let's say I create another rabbit
object okay all right there that's the
sad rabbit R to the ID of R 2 is going
to be what well according to the way we
inst the way we create a new rabbit
object is it's going to access whatever
the value of tag is which is a class
variable it was changed by the previous
creation of my rabbit so now I'm going
to access that right so the value is
going to be 2 and according to the code
the next thing I do after I create after
I create the instance our ID is I'm
going to increment tag so I'm
incrementing the class variable to be 3
so notice that all of my instances are
accessing this shared sort of the shared
sort of resource the shared variable
called tag so as I'm creating more and
more rabbits they're all going to be
incrementing the value of tag because
it's shared among all of the instances
and so the so this value this this tag
class variable sort keeps track of how
many different instances of a wrap of
how many different instances of rabbits
I've created throughout my entire
program so the big idea here is that
class variables are shared across all
the instances so they can all modify
them but these are IDs right these
instance variables are only are only for
that particular instance so R 2 can't
have access to our IDs our ones ID value
nor could change it but it won't change
it across all of the different instances
so so that's that's how the init method
works of rabbit okay so we have these
tags that keep track of how many rabbits
we've created we have a couple of get we
have some getters here to get all the
parents so now let's add a somewhat more
interesting function oh I just want to
mention when I'm getting the r ID I'm
actually using this cool Z fill function
here
which actually pads the beginning of any
number with however many zeros in order
to get to that number here so the number
one becomes zero zero one and so on so
it ensures that I have this nice-looking
sort of ID type thing that's always
three digits long so let's try to work
with this rabbit object let's define
what happens when you add two rabbits
together okay in this class not in the
real world okay so if I want to use the
plus operator between two rabbit
instances I have to Inc implement this
underscore underscore add underscore
underscore method so all I'm doing here
is I'm returning a new rabbit object
okay whoops sorry about that and let's
recall the init method of the rabbit
okay so when I'm returning a new rabbit
object I'm returning a new rabbit object
that's going to have an age of zero self
so the rabbit object I'm calling this
method on is going to be the parent of
the new OP of the new rabbit and other
is going to be the other parent of the
new rabbit okay so if we look at the
code
and I run it
this part here I'm creating three
rabbits r1 r2 and r3 notice this class
variable is is working as expected
because the IDS of each of my rabbits
increments as I create more rabbits so
we have zero zero one zero zero two zero
zero three if I print r1 and r2 and r3
that was these three lines over here the
parents of r1 and r2 are none because
that's just the default the default
argue but yes the default arguments for
creating a rabbit to add two rabbits
together I use the plus operator between
two rabbit objects and on the right here
I'm testing rabbit addition and I can
print out the the IDs of all my rabbits
and notice that when I've created this
new rabbit R for the idea of it still
kept incrementing so now the idea of the
fourth rabbit is double double of four
and then when I get our forced parents
they are as as we want them to be so r1
in our to the other thing I want to do
is to compare two rabbits so if I want
to compare two rabbits I want to make
sure that their parents are the same so
I can compare the parent of the first
parent of the first rabbit with the
first pair of the second rabbit and the
first parent of the second parent of the
first rabbit to the first second parent
of second rabbit or getting the
combinations of those two so that's what
these are these two boolean's are doing
so these are going to tell me these are
going to be boolean values either true
or false and I'm going to return either
way they have the same parents of that
type or the same parents criss-crossed
okay so here notice that I'm actually
comparing the IDS of the rabbits as
opposed to the rabbit objects directly
okay so if instead of doing instead of
comparing the IDS in here I was
comparing the parents themselves
directly what would end up happening is
this function this method EQ would get
called over and over again because here
we have parents that are rabbits and at
some point the parents of the very very
first rabbits ever created by this
program are none
and so when I try to call when I try to
call the parent one of none that's going
to give me an error okay something like
an attribute error where it doesn't nun
doesn't have a this parent attribute so
that's why I'm comparing IDs here okay
and the code in the lecture here shows
you some tests about whether rabbits
have the same parents and I've created
new rabbits here r3 and r4 the addition
of those two and our five and our six
are going to have the same parents down
here true but our foreign our six don't
okay so just to wrap it up
object-oriented programming is the idea
of correcting creating your own
collections of data where you can
organize the information in a very
consistent manner so every single type
of object that you creative of this
particular type that you create sorry
every object instance of a particular
type is going to have the exact same
data attributes and the exact same
methods okay so this really comes back
to the idea of decomposition and
abstraction in programming all right
thanks everyone